alien covenant hits theaters on may 19th
and fans can be more psyched formerly
known as Prometheus to and alien
Paradise Lost this latest installment in
the alien saga continues the story set
in motion by 2012's divisive prometheus
he is why we think this sci-fi horror
flick is going to be a return to form
for the Alien franchise and a big step
forward from the last movie xenomorph
while it may or may not be a traditional
alien movie alien covenant has at least
one thing that Prometheus didn't
xenomorph yeah those guys like the
poster for alien covenant that was
released in March 2017 this trailer is
crawling with aliens we've seen a face
hugger spring from an egg a new bar
busting ear morph and multiple shots of
Zeno more than familiar confines like
spaceship hallways and creepy caves
there's even a staredown between a
xenomorph and Danny McBride with nothing
but a spaceship windshield between them
what could that alien want hopefully
this
[Music]
HR Giger
is all over it visual artists HR Giger
is gone now but as long as the Alien
franchise exists his ghost will haunt it
the guy was into some spooky occult
stuff you don't make a book like the
Necronomicon and then peaceably
surrender to dust cold embrace you stick
around and horns tough starting with
your very own Museum in Switzerland and
continue with a whole bunch of Hollywood
blockbusters but back when alien
covenant was still Prometheus to
director Ridley Scott seemed intent on
going in a new direction stating
publicly that the film wouldn't feature
a xenomorph at all the beast is done
could of course we know that's not the
case anymore it's unclear what prompted
the subsequent about-face but maybe
Scott realized the gigas influence on
Prometheus was actually it's saving
grace say what you want about the
directing writing acting and characters
that movie is at least visually dazzling
digas alien Aesthetica featuring things
like slime biomechanics a metallic black
and blue palette and skeletal hinges is
an intrinsic part of the franchise and
from the looks of things Scott and his
team have realized that alien covenant
represents a step in the right direction
with regards to honoring gikas legacy
and keeping his ghost happy bringing
back body horror as important as gigas
concept art and designs have always been
the theater morph also owes just as much
to screenwriter dan O'Bannon's original
script the aliens anatomical anomalies
inspire real dread in the first Alien
movie and that's by design as a balance
said in a 2002 retrospective with alien
I'm going to attack the audience like
other great body horror movies alien
exploits movie goers fears of being
physically violated by using grotesque
imagery and gore alien covenants trailer
and other promo materials make prominent
use of the series strongest quality its
clever use of body horror tropes my body
is ready the new crew did you ever
wonder why a group of scientists would
remove their helmets on an alien planet
just because the air appeared to be
breathable you're not alone as Forbes
review puts it the characters in
prometheus too ridiculously dumb things
when they see black alien ooze they
touch it when they find a giant severed
alien head they bring it on the ship and
perform inexplicable experiments on it
they're supposed to be scientists yet
they behave like idiots so it's hard to
care when they die that's
said aliens crew had its fair share of
bad decision-making but it was always
grounded in the crews mutual experience
of working for a big corporation that
treated them as expendable the bonds
they shared with each other was both
professional and personal
the Nostrum whose fate was horrific
because audiences actually cared about
the crew by all appearances alien
covenant seems to correct one of
Prometheus's biggest missteps the
aloofness of its crew of scientists and
specialists which made them hard to
sympathize with in the prologue last
supper clip
the new crew lets loose and throws a
party to celebrate being the first
colonists on a mysterious planet
recasting the main characters as
colonists aligns it more closely with
Scotts original film and that's a good
sign music to your ears composer Jerry
Goldsmith and Lionel Newman's incredibly
tense corset alien apart from other
horror movies and if alien covenant
seeks to recapture the feel of the first
movie it will need a comparable score
fortunately there's a good bet that Jed
Cassell is up to the task you might
already know him as the lead singer of
the band of the metal he knows how to
create tension and he's a master serious
resume he scored his brother just incurs
else twenty eleven psychological horror
film snow tone first say what you will
about the rest of Assassin's Creed but
Creswell epic score was undeniably solid
as the trailers for a lien covenants
show crevo lets the on-screen action
influence the music allowing for low
ambient tones and dark tense sequences
stretches of silence during
conversations and a sweeping anthemic
accompaniment for the action horror set
pieces practical effects Ridley Scott is
known for having a healthy distrust of
CGI effects what does that mean / alien
covenant more the classic creature
feature practical effects that made the
first two films in the theory so
frightening to horror fans you can't
help but laugh at CGI monsters this is
welcome news Ridley Scott knows what
he's doing we're confident that Ridley
Scott will do right by fans of alien and
fans of Prometheus there's a lot riding
on alien covenant if it heads to sweet
spot in terms of box office grosses
Scott's promised as many as half a dozen
more alien movies as James Cameron put
it even not-so-great Ridley Scott films
are worth seeing because he is such an
artist put simply even a mediocre with
the Scott movie is still at least
intermittently compelling and we don't
expect that to change anytime soon let's
keep our fingers crossed that covenant
is the return
to form we're all hoping for thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]